now we're going to talk about the idea
of impedance this is a really important
idea in electronics and it's something
that comes from the study of ac analysis
and ac analysis is where we limit
ourselves to inputs to our circuits that
look like sinusoids cosines or sines
and of all the signals that we could
possibly have in the entire universe
we're going to limit ourselves just for
the moment to sine waves and there's
some great simplifications that emerge
from this
so in this video we're going to look at
we're going to develop basically the iv
equations for our three favorite uh
passive components resistor
inductor and capacitor
and we're going to look at those when
the input is a sinusoid
so that means that i or v the voltage of
the current is in the shape of a
sinusoid and we're going to see what
that means for the iv equations for our
favorite devices
so as we look at our iv equations with
sinusoid inputs we're actually going to
break down sinusoids into complex
exponentials
and when we studied sinusoids we we
found out that we could disassemble
sinusoids into complex exponentials
using euler's equation so for example if
we have a cosine wave if we have a
cosine as a function of time
omega t
we could express that in terms of
complex exponentials
like this one half
e to the plus
j omega t
plus
e to the minus j omega t
like that
and what i'm going to do now is i'm
going to say let's look at let's look at
what happens when we use this as an
input signal this is not a real input
signal it's an imaginary rotating vector
but if i have two of these i can
reassemble them into a cosine wave
and we like to use these exponentials
because they go through the differential
equations of a circuit really easily
these are the these are the inputs that
we know how to solve when we do
differential equations
so what i'm going to do is develop the
iv equations for the resistor inductor
and capacitor in terms of this kind of
an input when the voltage or the current
looks like this
what do those equations look like
so we're going to start with
we'll start with the resistor
here's a resistor
and we know from that that
just ohm's law is v equals i
times r
and just for the moment i'm going to
assume that the current let's assume
that i
equals
e to the plus
j omega t
so if this is i what is what is v for a
resistor well we just plug i in here and
we get v
equals
r times e
to the plus j omega t
all right
now i'm going to do something that looks
like it's a little too simple but it's
going to get interesting soon
i want to look at the ratio of voltage
to current
in this situation where we're driving
with this complex exponential
so voltage turned out to be
r
e to the plus j omega t
and that's the voltage i get if i put a
current through the resistor of e to the
plus j omega t
and what does that equal to well these
two are the same so they cancel
and i get the ratio of voltage to
current is r
for a
resistor
so for so for a resistor we just proved
that v over i
equals r
so this isn't news we didn't make a
discovery here this is just ohm's law
and for a resistor the voltage over the
current is always equal to the
resistance all right this is going to
get more interesting now as we go do
inductors and capacitors so let's do an
inductor
it has a value of l henry's
and for an inductor we know that voltage
equals
l
d i
dt
all right and let's do the same thing
again let's let i equal
e to the plus j omega t
so it's a complex exponential
current that we're forcing through our
inductor
and let's go ahead and work out what v
is so v
equals l times d
dt
of this value here
e to the plus
j omega t
or v equals now we take the derivative
and the j omega term comes down to
multiply
l
so we get j
omega
l
times what times the same thing
e to the plus j omega t this is the
beautiful thing about exponentials they
give us back themselves
all right so now let's do this let's
take once more let's what's the ratio of
voltage to current
and that equals here's the voltage
j omega l
times e to the plus j omega t
and let's divide that by i
which is i is right here
i is e
to the plus j omega t
so those cancel
and we get
v over i
equals
j
omega
l
so now we have an equation for v over i
for an inductor and this is interesting
this time we have
the inductance value which we expected
and there's also
this this omega j omega term that comes
in so this tells us this is frequency
omega is frequency so this tells us that
the ratio of v to i
for an inductor is dependent on
frequency
now we'll do the same thing for a
capacitor so here's a capacitor
and there's its capacitance value
inference and for the capacitor we know
that i
equals
c times dv dt
and this time let's let v of t
let's let v
equal e to the plus j omega t
so this time we're going to force a
voltage across our capacitor that is
this imaginary this complex exponential
and that gives us let's plug that in
here i
equals
c times d
dt
of
e to the plus
j omega t
and let's take that derivative
i equals
same thing happens j omega comes down to
multiply out in front with c and we get
the same thing over here so we get j
omega c
times
e to the plus j omega t
and now we'll ask the same question
again that we did before which is what
is what is v over i
for a capacitor
and we can fill this in v is sitting
right here v is e to the j omega t
e to the plus
j omega t
and the current is we work that out down
here
that's j
omega
c
times
e to the plus
j omega t
and once again we get this nice
cancellation here this cancels with this
and for a capacitor we get
v over i
equals
1 over
j omega c
let me put a box around that one too
so this says that the ratio of voltage
to current in a capacitor it depends on
the value of the capacitor of course
and it also depends on frequency so just
like over with the inductor we have a
frequency term in here
so now we're going to give this this
ratio of voltage to current
in all three cases we're going to give a
special name and that name is impedance
and the the symbol we often use for
impedance is a is a z
so this word impedance is the general
notion of the ratio of voltage to
current and we can do that for all three
of our our passive components
for a resistor the impedance is its
resistance r
so the word impedance is like the word
resistance except it's a more general
concept it's the general concept of
voltage divided by current
for a resistor the impedance is the
resistance
for an inductor
the impedance v over i is
j omega l
and down here for a capacitor the
impedance is 1 over j omega c for a
capacitance
so this is where the idea of impedance
this word impedance this is where it
comes from
and the idea includes both the the
values of the components and the effect
that frequency has on on the voltage to
current ratio so both of those things
are are combined into one idea
so just a quick summary of impedance if
we say the impedance
of a resistor that equals r
impedance of an inductor
equals
j omega l
and the impedance of a capacitor
equals 1 over
j
omega
c
and as a reminder of the assumptions we
made we said that we're only going to
consider sinusoidal inputs
and what we did is we broke up
our sinusoid our cosine wave into these
we looked at how these rotating vectors
pass through our our components in the
in in the form of voltages and currents
so there's no new physics here what
happened was we took these these j
omegas that came out of the exponentials
when we took the derivatives we
associated those with
the the component itself we did that
here and we did that here
and you can see it here so we've sort of
just done a it's it's it's somewhat of a
notational trick we associate this
frequency dependence not with the inputs
and the voltages and currents but with
the components themselves
and this is something we call this is
referred to as transforming
we've transformed our our components and
that's that's the phrase that's used
there but from this comes the idea of
impedance and in the general sense of
the voltage to current ratio